hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mindyourdecisions
this problem comes from a math
competition in croatia for 14 year olds
start with a triangle
from one vertex draw a line segment to
the opposite side
do the same thing from another vertex
the triangle is now divided into four
different regions
the areas of the triangles starting from
the left
are 3 4 and 2. the question is
what is the area of this quadrilateral
i thank mate for suggesting this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
the main principle in solving this
problem is the formula for the area of a
triangle which is one half its base
times its height
if you have a right triangle where this
is the base and this is the height its
area will be one half its base times its
height but the formula also holds as
long as a triangle has a fixed base and
its height is the same
so all of these triangles will have the
same area as the original right triangle
so how does this help us solve the
problem
well first we're going to need to do one
trick
we'll divide the quadrilateral right
down the middle
and divide its two areas as x and y we
want to solve for x plus y
so how can we do that well we'll use the
formula for the area of a triangle and
consider some ratios of areas of
triangles
for example consider this blue triangle
and this blue triangle
both of the triangles have the same
height as each other
so the ratio of their areas will be the
ratio of the lengths of their bases
let's call their bases b1 and b2
so the area of the top triangle will be
x plus y plus two the area of the bottom
triangle will be three plus four
and the ratio of these areas will be
equal to b1 over b2 and this is because
both of these triangles have the same
height
this simplifies to be x plus y plus two
all over seven is equal to b1 plus b2
so now let's look at some other ratios
of areas of triangles
here are two green triangles
both of these triangles have the same
height as each other so again the ratio
of the areas will be the ratio of the
lengths of their bases now these two
triangles have the same bases of b1 and
b2 as the previous blue triangles
so we have x over 3 is equal to b1 over
b2
so now we have two equations that are
both equal to b1 over b2
therefore we can set these two equations
equal to each other
now let's consider some different
triangles
let's consider these two triangles
these triangles have bases b3 and b4 and
just like we derived we can come up with
some similar formulas based on the areas
of these triangles
the ratios of these areas will be equal
to b3 over b4
so we have y plus x plus 3 the area of
the top triangle all over 2 plus 4 which
is 6.
this ratio will be equal to b3 over b4
now similarly if we take a look at these
two triangles the ratio of their areas
will also be equal to b3 over b4
so we have y over 2 is also equal to b3
over b4
so we can now
get rid of all these values of b1 b2 b3
and b4 because all we really care about
is the values of x and y
so we'll first cross multiply these
fractions
we'll cross multiply the fractions on
the top
then we'll cross multiply the fractions
on the bottom
we now have a system of two equations in
two variables x and y and we'll be able
to solve for unique values of x and y
so let me go through the steps very
quickly
first we'll group like terms
next we'll multiply the second equation
by two
now in order to solve this system one
thing we can do is we can add these two
equations
we'll get that negative 5y plus 18 is
equal to zero we've eliminated the x
variable by adding these two equations
thus we have y is equal to 18 over five
we can now use that value and substitute
it into the second equation and then
solve that x is equal to 21 over 5.
so we have values for x and y and
remember we want to solve for x plus y
so the area of this quadrilateral is
equal to x plus y which is 39 over 5 or
7.8
and that's our answer it took a little
bit of imagination to figure out the
magic line but then we used good
old-fashioned geometry and algebra to
solve it
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all the mind your
decisions videos and email me a puzzle
or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support